[Música]
bienvenidos a nuestro programa de medio
ambiente yo soy maría clara calle la
emisión de hoy está dedicada a celebrar
el día internacional de la madre tierra
que se conmemora el 22 de abril hace una
fecha es un llamado a actuar para
proteger nuestro planeta aunque la fecha
se celebra desde 1970 este es el primer
año que el día de la tierra se conmemora
en medio del decenio de la onu sobre la
restauración de los ecosistemas una
iniciativa que intenta detener y
revertir la degradación de los
ecosistemas que están dañados esto va
desde ríos y océanos hasta montañas y
áreas urbanas este día internacional de
la tierra también es una alerta de cómo
estamos destruyendo al planeta la onu
considera que de la tierra enfrenta una
triple emergencia por la crisis
climática la contaminación y la pérdida
de biodiversidad también la destrucción
se puede acelerar por deforestar cambiar
el uso del suelo y otras actividades
humanas como la producción agrícola y
ganadera a gran escala y el comercio
ilegal de la fauna y la flora silvestres
todas estas amenazas están teniendo
repercusiones graves según naciones
unidas cada año el mundo pierde 10
millones de hectáreas de bosques que es
un territorio casi tan grande como
islandia todo esto nos afecta
directamente a los humanos la crisis
climática por ejemplo se ha acelerado
tanto que cada vez son más frecuentes
los eventos extremos del clima como las
lluvias torrenciales de más de una
semana que obligaron a sudáfrica a
declarar emergencia natural en todo el
país
escribe that there el jazz es claro que
hay varias áreas del país que también
necesitan una intervención de emergencia
y el gabinete se reunió en una sesión
especial y decidió declarar un estado de
desastre nacional
y más de 440 personas han muerto y otras
40.000 perdieron sus hogares aunque la
declaración de emergencia es en toda
sudáfrica las inundaciones se han
concentrado en la región de
kwazulu-natal y han sido tan fuertes que
el mayor puerto del país ubicado en la
ciudad de durban pero durante días y es
que las costas sureste de áfrica donde
está co azul o natal son cada vez más
vulnerables a tormentas e inundaciones
los científicos señalan que es porque el
océano índico se está calentando más por
las emisiones que quedan atrapadas por
eso la tendencia son peores escenarios
incluso más graves que el de ahora
cuando sudáfrica ha padecido las lluvias
más fuertes en 60 años y para el
presidente la causa es clara
estas inundaciones son un trágico
recordatorio de la creciente frecuencia
de las condiciones extremas del clima
como un resultado del cambio climático
necesitamos aumentar nuestra inversión
en medidas de adaptación climática para
proteger mejor a las comunidades contra
los efectos del cambio climático facts
of climate change
y la crisis del clima también empeora
las sequías como las que se están
viviendo en irak en este país ha habido
al menos dos tormentas de arena en abril
cada una duró más de una semana y una
incluso cubrió a bagdad la capital como
resultado decenas de personas fueron
hospitalizadas por problemas
respiratorios estos eventos climáticos
son frecuentes en irak por la poca
lluvia y la alta temperatura del país
pero el escenario ha empeorado según la
oficina meteorológica
se espera un aumento de las tormentas de
polvo en irak debido a la sequía en la
desertificación y la escasez de lluvias
que debilitan la cubierta vegetal
además la sequía y la desertificación
amenazan el acceso al agua a 2050 irak
perderá el 20 por ciento de sus recursos
hídricos según el banco mundial ante
este panorama la ciudad de kerbalá al
sur de bagdad se propuso en 2006 crear
un cinturón verde la idea era sembrar
eucaliptos olivos y palmeras de dátil
para que sirvieran como barrera a las
tormentas de arena pero de los 76
kilómetros pensado sólo se han sembrado
un poco más de la mitad con 26
kilómetros en el eje norte y 22 en el
eje sur y es que el dinero no ha sido
suficiente
y en el día de la tierra también es
importante prender las alarmas sobre la
pérdida de biodiversidad
según la onu cerca de un millón de
animales y plantas están en peligro de
extinguirse en el pacífico norte una de
las víctimas es la ballena gris la
población de este mamífero marino cayó
de más de 26.000 individuos en 2016 a
cerca de 20.000 en 2021 muchas de las
ballenas mueren de hambre porque las
condiciones del océano se perturban el
año pasado
nos dimos cuenta de que
mucha ballena venía muy muy flaca
está muy desnutrida y créame que
sinceramente no mortificó esa situación
además de que no ha habido muchos partos
en los últimos años no nos informaba que
es la situación de la desnutrición de la
ballena por la cual no nos embaraza y la
que se embarazan en el transcurso del
trayecto cuando vienen de nuevo a estas
aguas este aborto en 2019 el pico de
muertes de ballenas grises fue tanta que
la oficina de administración oceánica y
atmosférica de eeuu declaró un evento
inusual de mortalidad en ese año de las
costas estadounidenses y en las de
canadá y méxico encontraron 216 ballenas
grises muertas en comparación de las 172
reportadas en 2020 y la 114 de 2021
según noam y los muere y las muertes no
han parado como se ve en la laguna sari
nació en méxico una de las áreas
protegidas para que estos mamíferos
puedan aparearse entre diciembre y marzo
antes de volver al polo norte
estamos hablando igual de una
disminución de un 75% sólo en algunas
salinas no toda su distribución pero
pues todo esto es
son síntomas de que algo está mal en la
población y esto se debe a problemas en
su alimento durante el verano donde se
alimentan las costas de alaska y los
males niveles
con este recorrido por algunas de las
crisis que atraviesa el planeta nos
despedimos en nuestro programa pueden
encontrar más de medio ambiente en
france 24
[Música]